you know what they say Dragon Ball and
Christmas go together like totally not
marks videos an airtight factual
analysis aka not at all and I'm not
kidding either Dragon Ball has
absolutely nothing to do with the
holiday season it's never even had a
single holiday episode based on any
religion or at least not as far as I
know in any case keeping religion out of
Dragonball is a good thing I think it is
rich in Buddhists and other Eastern
philosophies but Dragonball seems to
have its own thing going on and I think
that's one of the reasons why it's so
accessible for many people that said it
being Christmas week I have even less
time than usual to devise an episode
topic and have virtually no time to
produce one so Dragonball not having a
single shred of denominational value
isn't helping it's not gonna fly here no
siree and that my friends is when I got
an idea what if I count down the best
episodes that aired leading up to
Christmas in other words to qualify for
this the episode needs to have aired
somewhere between the 15th and the 25th
of December in Japan I'll be counting
down episodes from Dragon Ball Dragon
Ball Z TV specials and of course Dragon
Ball super Dragon Ball things that can
keep me from making a Christmas episode
go to Christmas the out of this
number 10 okay I know this doesn't look
great so far but believe me there are
some great episodes in this list we just
got away through the sewage system first
released on December 17th 2011 episode
of Bardock was a three chapter manga
created by neo Oh II sheet that was
turned into an anime it basically covers
the events of Bardock after he dies
apparently now thought this wasn't
enough and then said to himself you know
a paradox story needs these these things
are easily the most annoying wretched
addition to the franchise I mean just
look at them they're hideous dom
blobby barney turds
so Bardock and the blobby turns get into
trouble when the bad guy arrives this
little orange tie toby is called chilled
who pretty much looks like the physical
embodiment of being picked last for gym
class he couldn't look less threatening
even if he tried he's perpetually
wearing an orange leotard for shit's
sake needless to say I'm not the biggest
fan of this installment it devalues
Bionics character and ruins it in some
aspects it tries to become some
bigger than it is by tying its up into
the Super Saiyan legends origin and has
one of the most laughably bad discount
freezes I've ever seen the best thing to
come out of this special was team four
stars abridged adaptation ah nice
negative start to this Christmas episode
number nine you know this episode often
gets forgotten because it follows one of
the most iconic moments in the series
but this one always was one of my
personal favorites episode 121 of Dragon
Ball Z aired on December 18 1991 it
covers the aftermath of freezes to feed
the hands of trunks handles the quick
yet satisfying destruction of King
called and facilitates Goku's return oh
and there's a whole lot of mingling and
waiting around that takes up about 60%
of the episodes runtime but honestly I
didn't care this was a really feel-good
moment for me when I was watching the
show we forget this as adults but when
you're a little kid watching the show
Goku dying or not being around was kind
of a bummer I remember when I was a kid
my face lit up when trunks announced
that Goku was on his way home and as
Goku lifted himself out of that pod
I felt like an old friend had come back
it was a wonderful moment and it fits
perfectly in this list number eight now
I don't know about you but this is one
of my favorite episodes from the 25th
World Martial Arts Tournament airing on
December 22nd 1993 from start to finish
episode two one more of Dragon Ball Z
focuses on trunks and goten as they make
their way to the finals of the junior
division it's packed with moments like
this and scenes like that watching the
overconfident regular fighter come to
realize how screwed they really are is
one of the best aspects of these
tournament arcs the episode comes to a
head as we finally get to see gota and
fight one-on-one with trunks as both
their fathers watch from the sidelines
there's some very nice choreography and
it's so much fun to see these two new
characters interacting in such an
exciting way very fun episode number
seven sticking with trunks and goten for
this entry we find ourselves right in
the middle of the Buu saga in episode
251 of Dragon Ball Z airing on December
21st 1994 the episode serves as the
introduction to the very first fusion
dance fusion the series ever saw that
isn't the result majestic
fast forward to go to then trunks is
third attempt and we the viewer finally
get introduced to go tanks a boy whose
enormous power level is exceeded only by
his even more enormous ego no idea how
those clothes happen but whatever he
looks cool
the episode is filled with great comedic
moments as well as some decent action
scenes between go tanks and majin buu
now knowing wants to come for this
character the episode I think perfectly
sets the tone for what he goes on to
achieve and where he will ultimately
fail in this series number 6 switching
gears for a moment from Dragonball Z
let's take a look at episode 93 of
Dragonball on December 23rd 1987 came
tension on versus Jackie Chan in the
22nd World Martial Arts Tournament this
is one of the first proper glimpses we
get into tiens character in the series
apart from him being an arrogant dick to
everyone around him of course on top of
that this is the first time we the
viewers ctn's abilities tested as a
martial artist inside this episode there
are so many great exchanges between
Jackie Chan and TN most notably with
regards Jackie Chan aka Master Roshi in
disguise who comes to realize that his
time as the Earth's defender might be up
as the Warriors of a new generation
begin to take the stage he remarks this
detention hunt but he is of course
referencing Krillin Yamcha and goku in
that also there's some great fighting
animation that suits its era very well
and some great fight sequences if you
haven't seen it it's definitely worth
checking out number 5 at the halfway
point in this list comes Dragon Ball
super us first entry that's right I said
first and it's actually a good fun
episode titled the invisible killing
strike episode 72 of Dragon Ball super
aired on December 25th 2016 so it's
arguably the most Christmassy huh
just kidding the entire episode is spent
with hit trying to kill Goku but I'm
getting ahead of myself here acting as
the second part in a 2 episode mini Ark
this episode takes up right where the
last left off with Goku lying supposedly
dead in the floor after a fatal blow
from hit had been delivered on his
person however those that paid close
attention notice that Goku fired a ki
blast straight into the air before he
lost consciousness
this was 100% intentional we find out in
the next episode as he used
that exact same key blast to jumpstart
his heart and to regain consciousness
that itself is a pretty exciting opener
but it gets even better the fight brings
Goku and hit through some reading
interesting scenes we don't normally see
in Super and ultimately reaches a
conclusion in that same episode all in
all this is a really fun episode and
gives us great insight into his
character so thumbs up for this filler
episode actually giving us something
good but that's enough of that
let's jingle all the way to the next
entry number 4 ah we're back at good old
Dragon Ball and towards the end of the
series - no less episode 139 of Dragon
Ball aired on December 21st 1988 set in
the middle of the 23rd World Martial
Arts Tournament we get to see the
quarterfinals match between Yamcha and
shen the latter of which is under
commies control during this exchange
through supposed shenanigans Shen pulls
out the victory over Yamcha resulting in
his amusement however that was just the
appetizer as a semi finals match between
Goku and Tianjin hun is about to take
place and this match also acts as a
rematch to the finals of the last World
Martial Arts Tournament where tension on
took the victory over Goku while the
whole match is not featured in this one
episode it does contain the beginning as
the two Warriors feel each other out and
this is the first time we see Idol Goku
fight properly
it's so great getting to see these old
scenes in Dragonball again everything
from the AI silence the animation
practices are so nostalgic and well
Dragonball the exchange between tension
and Goku in this episode might not mean
a conclusion but it serves to foreshadow
just how strong Goku will become number
3 coming in at number 3 is our most
recent entry titled all-out war episode
121 of Dragon Ball super aired on
December 23rd 2017 set deep in the
tournament of power with less than 10
minutes remaining on the clock the
episode sees Goku Gohan Vegeta Android
17 and even fries that take on the
combined forces of universe 3 in the
form of a super bean called
an e Lassa the entire episode is spent
with universe 7 combating universe 3 is
most powerful being even resulting in
the elimination of Android 18
Frieza is even forced to join in and
lend a hand to put down this enormous
foe the episode comes to a head with the
elimination of University's final
warrior resulting in the final two
universes being 7
and 11 nah bad send off into the next
year number two some of you might be
wondering why I have an episode entitled
celebrations with majin buu so high up
on my Christmas list but in truth the
part that warranted this position had
little to nothing to do with majin buu
airing on December 20th 1995 this is the
episode right after Goku connects with
his spirit bomb on Kid Buu in the final
arc of the series the part that warrants
this number two position came at the
beginning as we see the aftermath and
the reuniting of many of the series
major characters prior to this acts
commencement Goku had been dead for
seven years and during this arc nearly
the entire main cast had either
sacrificed themselves or had been killed
this moment to me meant a lot I
remembered this being one of two moments
in the entire series where I was so
happy for the characters involved I
actually got a little emotional
chichi overjoyed an awestruck that Goku
is finally back and they can live a
quiet peaceful life as a family of four
for the first time it's a beautiful end
to this arc and one I will never forget
number one December 20th 1989 on
Japanese TVs across the nation the
public bared witness to a battle that
will be remembered in anime history for
years to come Goku vs. Vegeta not only
is this my number 1 episode for this
list but in general this is one of my
absolute favorite episodes in the entire
series including Dragon Ball Z and Super
Why because it has everything ground
combat aerial combat beam struggles
kaio-ken
and unpredictable transformations this
episode is a classic for a reason
and fun fact was my introductory episode
to the series so you could say without
this episode I might not be here today
making videos there's not much more I
can say about it except that it's an
all-time great and truly stands the test
of time if you haven't seen it do
yourself a favor and fix that right now
I know this list is sort of
unconventional but I thought it might
have been fun to build the video around
a specific date and see what episodes
popped up some of them were great
nostalgic and some were mediocre too
terrible and in a way isn't that what
Christmas is kind of all about dealing
with people you're only lukewarm on to
get to the great nostalgic feel that
Christmas promises
sometimes it's disappointing but
sometimes it can deliver a moment or two
you won't ever forget dragon ball isn't
specifically Christian Islamic Buddhist
or anything really and so regardless of
what your faith is or where you are I
would like to wish everyone here the
absolute best and a Happy New Year may
it be filled with plenty more wonderful
moments for you if you're feeling in the
seasonal mood as always comments or
ratings are very much appreciated I've
been totally not mark and thank you so
much for watching